Gary you've attached so many a-list
talent names to all of your projects for
anyone looking to cast similar names
what are some of the things they need to
know before they reach out to an agent
or manager
well the key of course is what's on the
page right if a KERS generally
especially stars and their handlers look
at a role first and the story second so
the role has to be really well developed
I spend countless months if not years
revising and working editorially with
with the writer to get the script just
so I think when you feel that you've got
something is really just brilliant and
that this is a role of a lifetime now
you're ready to go and the question at
that point is how do you create a cause
celeb and and and and and how do you how
do you get to those actors or their
handlers to to market it effectively to
them and I usually try and round up
support on the fringes right
you always want people echoing your
point of view who are closer to that
person one of the things that you want
to do is you want to first of all you
want to really research these actors and
see who's available and who's not what
you don't want you want to avoid to the
greatest extent possible submitting it
to someone where you're going to get a
note because they're unavailable
but the agencies now looked at it now
they already know it's been rejected
technically by one actor so you want to
kind of you know preset the table
knowing that someone's available knowing
that you can afford them so you have to
you have to have sort of a framework and
then I try and engage people that are
that are on their team starting with
assistance I always do that I always get
a champion inside whether it's the
casting directors office the agents
office the manager's office the
publicists office the attorney's office
anybody's office and I find out who's
the friendly warm one and I get them
talking amongst themselves and I tell
them what good is going on over here and
I create the sort of echo and I do that
in a few directions but bottom line the
things going to speak for itself the
script is I they can alight people up
and go home
what a great story what a perfect role
for my client unless you know the actor
personally you are going to deal with
all their handlers right their
representatives and so you really have
to be pretty straight ahead
I am very selective I send them a script
you know once a year is often frequent
for me so I know I'm very selective when
I send something they read it carefully
and then we have a talk when they reject
it if I think they're making a mistake I
will fight I will go back to the Asian
I'll go back to whoever's the
friendliest in the group and say I think
we need to have a further conversation
in one case the company passed and I
just simply said I refuse to accept your
pass I pass on your pass and I set up a
face-to-face that was my condition based
on our report I'm coming in for a
face-to-face is that okay and they said
of course and in the room I was able to
convince them and they actually turned
around their point of view and I got a
green light for a 42 million dollar film
so there's a level of persistence that's
appropriate but it's based on the nature
of the conversation you know if they see
something that's intriguing but they're
just not up to the to big risk for them
to say yes to put their star in it or
for the company to finance it or whoever
you're going after so you have to know
when to question when to move on to the
next candidate a common thing you'll
hear when you call one of these agencies
sorry so-and-so does not accept
solicited mang scripts how do you just
send anyway no I know it's actually one
of the it's a real breach of etiquette
to send any screen player intellectual
property that's not welcomed people
generally will return it unopened or
they'll open it and then realize what it
is and be upset it's not a great way to
set the table and that's for legal
reasons right so I never would submit
something unless they said please send
it but if they say no it's it's either
because they don't know you and they'll
say have a representative said in which
case you can have anybody act as your
rep it could be an attorney at the AE if
you don't have an agent from CA it's not
the end of the world you can have a lot
of people someone a young manager get a
fine a manager a loan a loan roll let
them do it
that's the buffer or they may say sign a
release releasing us from liability
because we don't know you and we don't
want to be sued sign the release your
job is to get your material read do you
want people to know your work to know
you as a creator that's more important
so don't worry about are they going to
steal it and very little get stolen
sign the release and send it
you